สวัสดีค่ะครูปุ๊กสวัสดีค่ะครูบีสวัสดีค่ะ
นักเรียนทุกคนค่ะค่ะสวัสดีนักเรียนทุกคน
เช่นกันค่ะค่ะขอต้อนรับนักเรียนนะคะเข้า
สู่ห้องเรียนภาษาไทยห้องเรียน
comprehensible ไทยค่ะอืนะคะห้องเรียน
ภาษาไทยแบบธรรมชาตินะคะวันนี้เรามาพบกัน
แล้วก็มาเจอกันในวันอะไรคะครูปุ๊กวันนี้
วันนี้วันศุกร์ค่ะวันศุกร์อ่าวันศุกร์วัน
ที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพ.ศอะไรคะ
2567 ปีค.ศอะไรคะ
2024 ค่ะนะวันนี้ครูปุ๊กครูบีเเนี่ยมาพบ
กับนักเรียนนะคะในวันศุกร์ที่ 16 เดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ปีพุทธศักราช 2567 ปี
คริสตศักราช
2024 ค่ะ
อ่าเดือนกุมภาพันธ์ก็ยังเป็นเดือนที่
เกี่ยวกับความรักนะคะ
อ้าเพผ่านมาแล้วใช่มั้ยคะ 14 กุมภาพันธ์
วันวาเลนไทน์วันเนี้ยวันที่ 16 แล้วอืถูก
ต้องค่ะนะแล้วครูปุ๊กมาเจอกับครูบีวัน
เนี้ยเราจะมาคุยกันเรื่องอะไรคะครูปุ๊ก
ครูปุ๊กเนี่ยมีเรื่องของนกค่ะนกนกๆนกจิ๊บ
ๆๆๆๆๆเออ
อ้าแต่นกอันเนี้ยส่วนมากเนี่ยคนก็จะรู้
สึกว่าเป็นสัญลักษณ์ของสิ่งที่ไม่ค่อยดี
เท่าไหร่ค่ะอ๋อถ้าเห็นนกตัวนี้ก็คือคิด
อืมโชคไม่ดีอะไรที่ไม่ดีใช่มยอ่าครูบีคิด
ซิว่านกอะไรนักเรียนคิดซินกอะไรคะครูบี
เนี่ยไอคดีแค่ฟังแค่เนี้ยก็รู้แล้วค่ะถ้า
เป็นนกที่คนไทยคิดว่าเอ๊มันจะไม่ดีนะเวลา
เห็นนกตัวเนี้ยก็ต้องเป็นก้าก้านี่แหละ
ค่ะอืนี่เลยถูกต้องแล้วค่ะนะเพราะว่ากา
เนี่ยมีสีดำเนาะแล้วคนไทยคิดว่าสีดำเนี่ย
มันบ่งบอกถึงเหมือนสิ่งไม่ดี
นะเห็นมยดำทั้งหมดเลยปากก็ดำนะหนก็ดำตาก็
ดำอืเอออะไรดำอีกก็ไม่รู้
เนาะแต่กแล้วก็มีนกอีกชนิดนึงเนาะนะอัน
นี้อ่าอันนี้เหมือนคนชอบเป็นความรักนะ
เหมือนหัวใจอืมนะอันนี้พอเราเห็นเนี่ยเรา
ก็เข้าใจเลยเนาะอันนี้เป็นหงส์ใช่มั้ยกู
ปุ๊กใช่ค่ะนะมันจะคล้ายๆกับห่านเนาะนะแต่
คอมันจะยาวกว่านะหงส์หงส์เนี่ยจะมีสีขาว
กับสีดำแต่มากๆแล้วเนี่ยเขาก็จะแบบกาเ
เนี่ยก็รู้สึกแบบโอ้โหหงส์เนี่ยสวยจังเลย
สวยมั้ยคะหงส์สวยสิคะสีขาวสะอาดดูแบบเป็น
แบบโอ้โหไฮโซดูแบบอืเหมือนคนมีเงินอ้าใช่
มเหมนเวลาว่าน้ำกับครูบีอ่ะครูปุ๊กกับครู
บีเเนี่ยดูแล้วใครดูมี
เงินไม่มีใช่
เออพยายาม
นะพยายามให้ดูดีนะเดี๋ยวครูบุ๊กต้องมี
เครื่องประดับก่อนค่ะจะได้ดูมีเงินค่ะอ่า
เห็นมยถ้าเกิดว่าเวลาที่เราเจอผู้หญิงสวย
ใส่เสื้อผ้ามีสร้อยคอพสร้อยเพชรสวยๆเราก็
จะรู้สึกแบบอุ๊ยผู้หญิงคนนี้ทั้งสวยทั้ง
รวยเอือนะรู้สึกอุ๊ยอิจฉาจังเลยทำไมเขา
สวยจังผิวขาวาออการอิจฉาเนี่ยก็คือรู้สึก
ว่าอยากจะเป็นเหมือนเขามยใช่เหมือนตอน
เนี้ยครูปุ๊กอิจฉาอ่ะไม่ใช่ครูบีไม่ใช่
ครูปุ๊กชื่อบีนะคะ
ลืมชื่อตัวเองอิจฉามากอ่ะเอออยากเป็นป
ปุ๊กมากอยากรีบพูดใช่มยตัวพูดแบบครูพุกจะ
แย่งพูดใช่
มั้ยชื่อครูบีนะครูบีเเนี่ยก็รู้สึกอยาก
เหมือนครูปุ๊กเพราะว่าชอบดูหน้าครูปุ๊ก
อ้วนใช่
มยผิวค่ะผิวผๆอ๋อ
ผิวผิวครูปุ๊กเนี่ยผิวขาวอมชมพูอุ๊ย
อืไม่มีขนเดี๋ยวๆครูบีตอนนี้คือครูบีใช้
เอฟเฟคอยู่นะเดี๋ยวจะปิดเอฟเฟคเห็นมย
อ่าเนี่ยๆๆครูปุ๊กปิดเอฟเฟคก็คือปิดกล้อง
ค่ะอ่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยเป็นคนผิวขาวใช่มยหน้า
ครูปุ๊กก็ขาวแล้วก็อมชมพูส่วนครูเนี่ยผิว
ออกแบบสีดำเนาะสีน้ำผึ้งนะอใช่อ่าอร่อย
อือหืออาจจะเค็มนิดๆอร่อย
นะนะเพราะว่านักเรียนอาจจะชอบผิวภูบีแล้ว
แต่เนาะว่าคนใครชอบแบบไหนนะแต่ว่าแน่นอน
ล่ะคนไทยเองเนี่ยเราก็จะรู้สึกว่าคนที่
ผิวขาวเนี่ยก็สวยกว่าผิวดำใช่มั้ยคะใช่
เพราะว่าครูปุ๊กเนี่ยดู
สะอาดจริงๆไม่ได้อาบน้ำค่ะสกปรกใช่ค่ะครู
ปุ๊กผิวขาวเนี่ยเราก็คิดว่าครูปุ๊กเป็นคน
สะอาดอาบน้ำบ่อยๆใช่มั้ยคะจริงๆครูปุ๊ก
ไม่ชอบอาบน้ำนะแต่ผิวเนี่ยดูสะอาดมากนะคะ
อาฮะไม่ชอบอาบน้ำกับกลัวน้ำไม่เหมือนกัน
นะคะครูบีเเนี่ยก็ชอบผิวแบบครูปุ๊กไงใส่
เสื้อสีอะไรก็สวยใช่มยครูบีก็เลยรู้สึก
แบบอิจฉาอยากมีผิวสวยเหมือนครูปุ๊กอ่ะใช่
มยอ่าเพราะว่าคนไทยเนี่ยชอบผิวสีขาวมาก
กว่านักเรียนก็จะได้ไม่คิดว่าเอ๊ะทำไมถึง
ครูปุ๊กผิวดีกว่ากูบียังไงนักเรียนอาจจะ
ชอบผิวกูบีไงนะแต่อันนี้เนี่ยถ้าในประเทศ
ไทยเนาะคนไทยคิดเนี่ยก็คือผิวขาวก็ดีกว่า
ผิวสีค้ำสีอน้ำผึ้งหรือสีดำก็แล้วแต่เนาะ
นะก็คือทุกคนประมาณว่าอาจอ่าก็อาจจะมีคน
เนี่ยชอบผิวผิวเหมือนครูบีเนาะบางทีเราก็
พูดทับศัพทว่าผิวแทนใช่มั้ยผิวผึ้งหรือ
ว่าผิวคล้ำผิวดำออได้หมดนะคะอ่าคือมันก็
มีคนที่ชอบแต่เปอร์เซ็นต์มันน้อยนะเพราะ
ว่าคนไทยเนี่ยจะรู้สึกว่าผิวขาวเนี่ยมัน
มันสวยใส่เสื้อผ้าอะไรก็สวยประเทก็เลยมี
แต่ไิโลชนะคะอืใช่ค่ะนะก็เพราะว่าคนไทย
มากๆเนี่ยจะมีผิวสีเดียวกับครูบีเยอะนะ
แตู่กุ๊งเนี่ยเป็นคนไทยผสมจีนคนจีนเนี่ย
เขาจะผิวขาวเราูก็เลยได้สีขาวจากคุณแม่มา
นะอนะแต่ถ้าเป็นคนยุโรปนะก็ผิวขาวเยอะใช่
มั้ยพอมาเจอคนไทยผิวเหมือนครูบีก็บอกว่า
มันสวยเห็นมั้ยคะประเทศไทยก็มีผิวแบบครู
บีเยอะเห็นขาวๆแบบครูปุ๊กก็บอกว่าสวยเอ้อ
ครูบีเนี่ยฝรั่งเห็นครูปุ๊กก็จะรู้สึกผิว
น่ะเอธรรมดาไม่สวยก็ฝรั่งก็ผิวเหมือนครู
ปุ๊กไงสีขาวก็รู้สึกธรรมดาแต่ครูบีค่ะครู
บีเห็นครูปุ๊กแล้วรู้สึกอิจฉาค่ะอือทำไม
ฉันผิวไม่สวยเหมือนครูปุ๊กอือื
อืมนะเหมือนกาเลยค่ะครูบีครูปุ๊กว่าครูบี
เป็นกาเหรอคะไม่ใช่เหมือนกาในที่นี้ก็คือ
ว่าในเรื่องเนี่ยอืกาเนี่ยเค้าก็บินๆมา
ใช่มยหาอาหารกินๆแล้วก็เห็นหงส์เนี่ยว่าย
น้ำเล่นเนี่ยก็รู้สึกว่าโหงส์เนี่ยสวยจัง
เลยอืมสิคอก็ยาวนะแล้วก็เวลาว่ายน้ำเนี่ย
เหมือนเหมือนไฮคลาสใช่มั้ยอืนะไม่แบบไม่
ได้แบบว่ายน้ำ
แบบใช่มั้ยเจะแบบมีคอยาวๆแล้วก็แบบโอ้โห
ดูสง่าดูสวย
อืก็กาก็เลยมาเห็นหงส์เนี่ยก็รู้สึกแบบ
โหหงส์เนี่ยน่าอิจฉาจังเลยอ่ะทำไมมีคน
เนี่ยสีขาวนะขาวเนี่ยต้องเปรียบเทียบด้วย
คุณบีขาวเหมือนอะไรคะอืก็ขาวเหมือนสำลีนะ
คะออือนะสำลีนะสำลีก็คือเป็นเวลานักเรียน
ไปหาคุณหมอเนอะแล้วต้องฉีดยาเนี่ยฉีดยา
ใช่มยเ้าก็จะมีแอลกอฮอล์แล้วก็มีสำลีสี
ขาวเนอะไม่ใช่ทิชชู่นะสำลีแล้วก็ใส่
แอลกอฮอล์แล้วก็เช็ดๆที่แขนเราแล้วก็เอา
เข็มขึ้นมาเนี่ยแล้วก็ฉีด
นะก็เช็ดแอลกอฮอล์นะที่สำลีสำลีก็มีสีขาว
แล้วก็สะอาดใช่มยอืใช่ค่ะเนี่ยสสลีเนี่ย
สีขาวใช่ค่ะเวลาเราเห็นอะไรที่เป็นสีขาว
เนี่ยสะอาดนะคะหน้าใช้เห็นมยใช่ถ้าแบบ
ต่างประเทศก็อาจจะแบบเปรียบเทียบกับหิมะ
ที่ตกมาใหม่ๆเนาะมันก็อาจจะสีขาวมั้งนะฮ
ก็บางคนก็เปรียบเทียบแบบนั้นไงเหมือน
สโนวไวท์ไงอืเออแล้วคิดดูว่าหงส์เนี่ยก็
เป็นสีขาวซึ่งหงส์เนี่ยครูปุ๊กจะเห็นว่า
เวลาเราพูดถึงผู้หญิงสวยเราก็จะเปรียบ
เทียบว่าสวยเหมือนหงส์ใช่มั้ยออ่าแล้วก็
ครูปุ๊กเคยครูปุ๊กมีเพชรใช่มั้ยในเมื่อ
กี้อ่ะสร้อยเพชร
อืนี่เพชรๆๆบางคนเนี่ยเวลาซื้อสร้อยเพชร
เนี่ยยังเป็นรูปหงส์เลยค่ะแพงมากด้วยครู
ปุ๊กอืนะอืเพราะว่ารูปหงส์เนี่ยจะสวยนะ
เพราะเป็นแบบที่มีคอยาวนะแล้วก็มีเวลา
ว่ายน้ำูบอกแล้วเขาจะแบบเหมือนคอเนี่ย
ตั้งเชิดอนะก็เลยรู้สึกแบบโอ้โหเหมือน
ไฮโซนะอืนะสีขาวคอยาวสวยอ่ากาเเนี่ยก็เลย
รู้สึกว่าทำไมหงส์ถึงสวยขนาดนี้ใช่มั้ยทำ
ยังไงอ่ะเราถึงจะเหมือนหงส์ได้อ๋อกาอยาก
จะเหมือนหงส์อยากจะเป็นเหมือนหงส์ใช่ค่ะ
อยากจะมีสีขาวขนสีขาวนะเพราะไม่อยากเป็น
กาที่มีแต่ขนสีดำอแล้วก็เลยคิดไปว่า
อ๋อคิดว่านะน่าจะต้องมาดูชีวิตความเป็น
อยู่ของหงส์ว่าหงส์เนี่ยอยู่ยังไงอะไรอืม
นะโอต้องไปดูอย่างงั้นเลยหรอครูปุ๊กเอ้า
ก็กาก็คิดไงว่าถ้าเราทำเหมือนหงส์เนี่ย
เราก็อาจจะมีขนขาวสวยเหมือนหงส์ก็ได้นะอ
กาก็เลยมาดูว่าหงส์เนี่ยใน 1 วันเนี่ยทำ
อะไรบ้างก็เห็นแต่หงส์เนี่ยว่ายน้ำว่าย
น้ำอยู่แต่ในน้ำอืแล้วก็กินเนี่ยสสาหร่าย
ใช่มยนะสาหร่ายสาหร่ายทะเล
นะสาหร่ายแม่น้ำก็ได้สาหร่ายที่อยู่ในแม่
น้ำก็ได้ใช่มั้ยหงส์หงส์กินสาหร่ายเหรอคะ
ครูปุ๊กใช่ค่ะนะจริงๆหงส์ก็ไม่ค่อยว่า้
น้ำทะเลนะจะว่า้อยู่ในแม่น้ำที่เราจะเห็น
นะนะก็ก็จะกินพวกต้นไม้ในน้ำอ่ะเป็น
สาหร่ายเป็นอะไรอย่างเงี้ยตะไข่ไม่รู้อ่ะ
นะหงส์ก็กินกาเนี่ยก็เฝ้าดูว่าหงส์เนี่ย
วันๆนึงทำอะไรบ้างอืมอ่าแล้วกาก็เลยคิด
ว่าอหงส์ทำแบบเนี้ยมันก็เลยดูขนเป็นสีขาว
อือเพราะฉะนั้น
เนี่ยเดี๋ยวเราจะต้องทำตัวเหมือนหงส์นะ
เราก็อาจจะเป็นเหมือนหงส์ไงนะแล้วต้องทำ
ยังไงอ่ะกาก็เลยไ้น้ำนทุกวันบ้างนะก็มา
ว่ายน้ำอาหารการกินที่เคยกินก็ไม่กินนะก็
กินเหมือนหงส์ทุกวันก็มาว่ายน้ำว่ายน้ำ
แล้วก็คุยกับหงส์หงก็ถามว่า
อ้าวเจ้าเนี่ยทำไมทำไมมาว่ายน้ำแบบนี้อ่า
ทำไมไม่ไปหาอาหารกินอืนะแต่การก็บอกว่า
ฉันก็อยากจะว่ายน้ำทุกวันบ้าง
อ่ากินอาหารเหมือน
เธออยากจะว่ายน้ำทุกวันแล้วก็กินอาหารที่
อยู่ในน้ำกินสาหร่ายที่อยู่ในน้ำแบบนี้ลอ
คะใช่ค่ะนะแล้ว
ก็คิดว่ากาก็คิดหึฉันก็จะได้เหมือนเธอไง
อืม
เพราะว่าฉันเนี่ยเฝ้ามองเธอมาตั้งนานแล้ว
ว่าเธอเนี่ยมีขนสีขาวสวยมากอืนะแล้วก็เธอ
เนี่ยดูสวยงามฉันก็อยากจะเป็นเหมือนเธอออ
เพราะว่าถ้าเราเห็นหงส์ทุกตัวเนี่ยเห็น
มั้ยสีขาวหมดเลยเนาะครูปุ๊กแล้วก็สวยแต่
กาเนี่ยสีดำใช่ปกปกติกาเนี่ยไม่ชอบว่าย
น้ำใช่ค่ะกาเนี่ยโดยปกติชีวิตเขาเนี่ยก็
จะบินหาอาหารกินแมลงกินอะไรอ่ะซากสัตว์
อะไรก็ได้อ่ะเค้ากินเนื้อสัตว์ได้ไงนะมาก
ๆแล้วก็จะไม่ได้กินผักผลไม้หรือกิน
สาหร่ายแบบนี้นะออกาก็เลยอยากเปลี่ยนตัว
เองแล้วก็อือกินเหมือนหงส์ว่ายน้ำเหมือน
หงส์คิดว่าว่ายน้ำเหมือนหงส์กินเหมือน
เหมือนหงส์ใช้ชีวิตเหมือนหงส์แล้วก็จะได้
สวยเหรอคะใช่ค่ะนะกาก็เลยไปว่ายน้ำนะหงส์
ก็ยังบอก
ว่าท่านเนี่ยมาว่ายน้ำแบบนี้เนี่ย
ทำไมถ้าไม่ไปหาอาหารกินเนี่ยระวังเดี๋ยว
จะไม่สบายอือืเออแต่กาเเนี่ยก็ไม่เชื่อนะ
เพราะว่ากาก็คิดด้วยตัวเองได้ใช่มั้ยว่า
เฝ้ามองหงส์อยู่ทุกวันเนี่ยชีวิตประจำวัน
ของหงส์ก็ไม่เห็นมีอะไรก็ว่ายน้ำอแสดงว่า
ว่ายน้ำแล้วเนี่ยขนมันอาจจะเป็นสีขาวไงอื
นะสีดำเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นเพราะว่าสกปรกก็เลย
สีดำเพะว่า้น้ำมากๆขนก็เลยสีขาวอ้าวแล้ว
ทำไมไหงส์ถึงบอกว่าอีกาว่ายน้ำแบบนี้
ระวังนะจะไม่สบาย
ออเพราะว่าคือถ้ากาเเนี่ยลงมาเล่นน้ำกิน
น้ำบ้างนะเล่นน้ำนิดหน่อยแล้วก็บินไปใช้
ชีวิตของกาเหมือนเหมือนกาทั่วๆไปเนี่ยนะ
มันก็ไม่ได้มีปัญหาไงครูบีนะแต่อันเนี้ย
กาตัวเนี้ยเค้าอยากเป็นเหมือนหงส์เพราะ
ว่ารู้สึกอิจฉาหงส์ที่มีขนขาวสวยงามนะมี
ท่าทีเนี่ยรู้สึกแบบโอหว่ายน้ำเนี่ยสวย
มากเขาก็เลยอยากเป็นเหมือนหงส์ไงอืก็เลย
ใช้ชีวิตเหมือนหงส์ก็คือว่ายน้ำทั้งวัน
น่ะซึ่งมันผิดปกติของกาอ่าว่ายน้ำทั้งวัน
ก็จะไม่สบายได้เนาะเพราะปกติกาเนี่ยจะบิน
หาอาหารแต่หงคือเค้าอยู่กับน้ำอยู่แล้วอ
ว่ายน้ำอยู่แล้วใช่มั้ยคะใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
สัตว์แต่ละชนิดก็จะมีลักษณะนะวิธีการอยู่
อาศัยเนี่ยที่ไม่เหมือนกันนะแต่ว่ากา
เนี่ยเข้าใจผิดคิดว่าการที่ว่ายน้ำเนี่ย
มันจะทำให้ขนเนี่ยเป็นสีขาวเห็นมยกาเนี่ย
ชีวิตเนี่ยก็ต้องบินไปอยู่บนต้นไม้ใชา
อาหารแต่หงส์เการใช้ชีวิตเนี่ยคืออยู่
อยู่ในน้ำตลอดเลยเห็นมั้ยคะอือหือ
อแล้วีนี้กาจะไม่เหนื่อยหรอคะครูปุ๊กมัน
ก็เหนื่อยแต่ด้วยความที่อิจฉาแล้วอยาก
เป็นไงอยากเป็นเหมือนคนอื่นไงก็เลยแบบ
พยายามคิดว่าเอ่อหิวก็ลองกินสาหร่ายนะแต่
ว่ากาเนี่ยพอกินสาหร่ายเนี่ยมันก็จะไม่
ได้แข็งแรงไงโดยชีวิตความเป็นอยู่ของกล้า
เนี่ยมันต้องกินเป็นพวกเนื้อสัตว์นะหรือ
แมลงอะไรแบบเนี้ยนะมันก็เลยแบบเริ่มแบบ
ไม่มีแรงอื
เออเหมือนครูบีกินปกติกินสเต็กใช่มั้ยกิน
เนื้อสัตว์เนี่ยบางคนบอกโอ้กินแล้วมันรู้
สึกมีพลังแข็งแรงนะแต่บางคนแบบกินเจียน
เนาะกินผักวีแกนหรืออะไรอย่างเงี้ยกินผัก
กินผลไม้นะแล้วกินเนี่ยนะมันก็จะแบบ
เหมือนแรงมันจะน้อยกว่านะอืเนาะเพราะว่า
ใกล้ง่ายก็จริงโดยปกติกาเเนี่ยก็ไม่ได้
กินเหมือนหงส์หงอยู่ในน้ำก็จะกินอ่าพวก
สาหร่ายได้ใช่มั้ยแต่ถ้าเป็นกาเนี่ยกาเ
เนี่ยส่วนมากก็จะกินแมลงกินหนอนกินอ่าซาก
พืชซากสัตว์อะไรอย่างเงี้ยเหมือนสัตว์ที่
ตายอย่างเงี้ยนะนยังเนๆก็กิน
ได้ใช่กินอาหารแบบนี้ทีเนี้ยพอกินสหร่าย
ไปก็จะแบบโอไม่ค่อยสบายไม่มีแรงอ่าก็ว่าย
น้ำทั้งวันเนี่ยมันมันไม่ใช่วิธีการชีวิต
ความเป็นอยู่ของกาเพราะฉะนั้นเนี่ยน้ำมัน
ก็จะมีความเย็นเนาะนะแล้วตัวการเองก็ว่าย
อยู่ในน้ำก็หมดแรงไปเรื่อยๆนะจนในที่สุด
เนี่ยมันก็เลยตายเลยค่ะ
หะอยากเหมือนหงส์ไม่ฟังหงส์บอกว่าไม่ต้อง
ทำแบบนี้อแต่กาเนี่ยก็ยังทำยังว่ายน้ำจน
ตัวเองไม่สบายไม่มีแรงจนตายเลยหรอูปุ๊ก
ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่ามันก็เหนื่อยเนเหนื่อยมาก
จนแบบอาจจะจมน้ำตายหรือว่าไม่มีเรี่ยวแรง
หมดแรงนะอาหารก็ไม่ได้กินอาหารที่ตัวเอง
เคยกินไงนะเห็นมยเค้าบอกว่าจริงๆแล้วอ่ะ
นะเราอ่ะต้องพอใจในตัวเองอืมนะไม่ต้อง
อิจฉาใครใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะครูบีเเนี่ยผิวแบบ
นี้ก็สวยใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะนะผิวแบบครูบีเนี่ย
จะทนกับแสงแดดได้มากกว่าผิวของครูปุ๊กอื
เวลาครูปุ๊กโดนแสงแดดเนี่ยอาจจะเป็นเซลล์
มะเร็งได้นะมะเร็งเนี่ยอาจจะทำให้เป็น
มะเร็งผิวหนังแต่ผิวบีจะทนกว่านะก็อันนี้
ก็มีข้อดีใช่มยอ่าผิวแบบเวลามีแสงแดดก็
แข็งแรงมากกว่าผิวขาวแบบขูปุ๊กนะคะใช่ค่ะ
เพราะเพฉนั้นเนี่ยทุกอย่างเนี่ยมันมีข้อ
ดีข้อเสียนะแล้วบางคนเนี่ยพยายามเป็น
เหมือนคนอื่นไงอืชีวิตเนี่ยก็จะไม่ได้มี
ความสุขอืบางคนเนี่ยอิจฉาคนอื่นแล้วก็แบบ
ทำไมฉันไม่เป็นแบบนั้นทำไมฉันไม่สวย
เหมือนคนนั้นทำไมฉันไม่ดีเท่าคนนั้นทำไม
ฉันไม่รวยเหมือนคนนั้นเงี้ยครูปุ๊กคะ
สมมุติครูบีเเนี่ยอิจฉาครูปุ๊กที่ผิวขาว
มากใช่มั้ยอือครูบีก็อยากขาวไงทำยังไงดี
คะฉีดค่ะมีเข็มมั้ยมีค่ะ
นะฉีดอะไรคะฉีดผิว
อืแต่ไม่มีเงินก็ไปฉีดกับคุณหมอแต่ไม่ใช่
คุณหมอจริงๆเห็นมั้ยครูปุ๊กจะดูข่าวที่
ทีวีมีผู้หญิงไทยเนี่ยไปฉีดผิวแล้วก็ตาก
นะเหมือนเหมือนกาเลยค่ะ
อ๋ออยาก
ขาวเนี่ยแหละเพราะว่าเวลาเห็นคนอื่นแล้ว
เราก็คิดว่าคนอื่นเคคดีกว่าแล้วก็อยาก
เป็นเหมือนเค้าบางคนเนี่ย
อิจฉาอิจฉาคนอื่นอย่างเงี้ยคือชีวิตมันก็
ไม่มีความสุขเนเพราะว่าได้แต่คิดว่าทำไม
เราไม่เป็นเหมือนเค้าออืออะไรอย่างเงี้ย
ไม่ชอบเค้าเพราะว่าเค้าสวยไม่ชอบเพราะว่า
เครวยอะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะหรือว่าบางคนพยายาม
ทำตัวให้เหมือนเพื่อนนะเพื่อนรวยเราจน
อย่างเงี้ยเค้ารวยเค้ามีเงินซื้อเสื้อผ้า
แบรนด์เนมมีนะมือถือแบบ iPhone อย่าง
เงี้ยรุ่นใหม่ตัวเองไม่มีเงินแต่พยายามทำ
เหมือนกับเพื่อนเพราะว่ารู้สึกว่าตัวเอง
ก็จะได้เหมือนเท่ากันกับเพื่อนนะก็ไปยืม
เงินหรือขอเงินคุณพ่อคุณแม่จนไม่มีอะไร
ให้แล้วก็เอาของไปขายใช่มั้ยนะเพื่อจะ
ซื้อจะเปลี่ยนเอาแบบให้ตัวเองเนี่ยเหมือน
กับเพื่อนนะอ่านะอันนี้ก็จะทำให้ไม่มี
ความสุขเนาะแล้วก็บางทีก็อาจจะเป็น
อันตรายถึงตายได้นะคะอือฮึนะเห็นมั้ยหลาย
ๆคนเนี่ยไอ้ความอิจฉาเนี่ยมันทำให้สุขภาพ
จิตเราไม่ดีเนาะอืมนะบางคนเนี่ยไม่รู้ตัว
ด้วยนะว่าเป็นคนที่อิจฉาอ่าอิจฉาว่าเค้า
ซวยกว่าฉันก็อืไปทำให้ตัวเองสวยกว่าออแต่
ไม่มีเงินนะอ่าไม่มีเงินแต่ว่าไปขโมยเงิน
คุณแม่แล้วก็ไปคลินิกทำสวยนะอันนี้ขโมย
เงินคุณแม่ยังไม่เท่าไหร่นะอาจจะไปปล้น
ร้าน
ทอง
เอาโทงใช่มั้ยแล้วก็คิดเอาไปเปลี่ยนเป็น
เงินเอันนี้ก็ทำไม่ดีเพราะว่าคิดว่าอยาก
มีเงินเยอะๆจะได้เปลี่ยนตัวเองไปทำ
ศัลยกรรมจมูกเล็กๆก็เอาทำให้มันจมูกโด่ง
ใช่มยตาเล็กๆก็อยากตาโตเหมือนครูบีก็ไปทำ
ตา 2 ชั้น
ค่ะปากเล็กๆก็อยากจะปักอืปากสวยๆเหมือน
ครูบีเออ
ถ้าเราอยากสวยยเราก็ต้องใช้เงินตัวเองใช่
มยอันนี้โอเคเนาะแต่ถ้าอิจฉาแล้วไปทำทำ
ให้ตัวเองเดือดร้อนทำให้คุณพ่อคุณแม่
เดือดร้อนก็ไม่โอเคหรือบางคนอิจฉาที่ครู
ปุ๊กสวยกว่าอก็อาจจะเอาน้ำเนี่ยน้ำกรดไป
สาดครูปุ๊กก็ได้เออนะน้ำกดมันเป็นเอสิก
มันก็จะกัดๆๆๆๆหน้าครูปุกก็จะเละเลยทีนี้
อืเอ้าบางคนอิจฉามันก็เป็นโรคชนิดนึงเนาะ
เหมือนแบบเสียสุขภาพจิตเลยนะอืใช่ๆเอ้า
ธรรมดาเในครอบครัวบางทีน่ะพี่น้องก็อิจฉา
กันเองก็มีเพราะว่าบางทีเนี่ยเวลาน้อง
เกิดใหม่เนี่ยพี่เนี่ยเคยพ่อแม่เนี่ยรัก
อุ้มทุกวันอุ้มทั้งวันนะแต่พอมีน้องปุ๊บ
ไม่อุ้มพี่ก็จะรู้สึกแบบโกรธอืนะก็จะ
อิจฉาว่าทำไมอ่ะต้องอุ้มแต่น้องทำไมไม่
อุ้มตัวเองอนะบางทีก็ตีใช่มั้ยตีน้องแอบ
ตีน้องอือันนี้ก็คือพี่อิจฉาน้องนะถ้าคุณ
พ่อคุณแม่มีลูก 2 คนใช่มั้ยอ่าอันนี้ก็
เป็นแบบเด็กๆไงเด็กๆก็ยังโอเคนะอ่าแต่ถ้า
อิจฉาแล้วมันแบบอิจฉาอิจฉาทุกอย่างอุ้ย
ทำไมน้องเก่งกว่าทำไมคุณพ่อคุณแม่รักน้อง
มากกว่าอันนี้จะกลายเป็นอิจฉาแล้วก็คิด
ไม่ดี
อืคิดไม่ดียังไม่เท่าไหร่ถ้าทำไม่ดีด้วย
เนี่ยอืนะมันอาจจะแบบเนน่ากลัวใช่ค่ะอาจ
จะไปทะเลาะตกตีกันอาจจะทำให้เขาเสียโฉม
เนาะบางคนอาจจะมีมีดคัตเตอร์แล้วก็อยาก
สวยกว่าใช่มั้ยสวยกว่าหรออุ๊ยทำไมเหมือน
ครันนี้ครูปุ๊กน่าจะอิจฉาครูบีที่สวยกว่า
ใช่ค่ะนะเออนะก็เหมือนกาเนาะกาเเนี่ยก็
ไม่พอใจที่ตัวเองเป็นแบบนี้นะอยากเหมือน
หงส์อซึ่งพออยากเหมือนหงส์ไปใช้ชีวิตแบบ
หงส์เนี่ยมันก็เหนื่อยไงว่ายน้ำทั้งวัน
เอ่าแล้วตัวเองก็กินอาหารก็ไปกินเหมือน
หงส์อีกก็ไม่มีแรงพอไม่มีอาหารกินไม่มี
แรงก็จมน้ำตายเห็นมั้ยคะอืมใช่ค่ะเห็น
มั้ยอะไรทุกอย่างเนี่ยก็คือให้เราพอใจใน
สิ่งที่ตัวเองเป็นอยู่มีอยู่นะเพราะว่า
เมื่อไหร่ที่เราน่ะมีความอิจฉาเนี่ยนะมัน
จะไม่มีความสุขค่ะเพราะว่าสมองก็จะคิดทำ
ยังไงทำยังไงให้เราเนี่ยสวยเหมือนเค้าทำ
ยังไงให้เรารวยเหมือนเค้าหรือว่าทำไม่ดี
กับเค้าอย่างเงี้ยมันก็จะไม่ดีไงนะเพราะ
ว่าบางคนเนี่ยเหมือนคิดจะแข่งอืนะแข่งมี
เพื่อนแล้วเพื่อนแบบโอ้โหทุกคนชอบเพื่อน
คนนี้มากๆไม่ชอบฉันอย่างเงี้ยฉันจะต้องทำ
ให้เพื่อนชอบฉันอย่างเงี้ยก็ซื้อของไปให้
เพื่อนบ้า่งทำยังไงก็ได้เพื่อนจะได้มาชอบ
อะไรอย่างเงี้ยนะหรือไปบอกเพื่อนว่าคนนี้
ไม่ดีไม่ดีไอ้นู่นไม่ดีไอ้นี่ก็คือไปโกหก
คนอื่นออพูดไม่ดีใช่มั้พูดพูดว่าเพื่อน
เนี่ยเป็นคนไม่ดีให้คนอื่นเไม่ชอบเพื่อน
ตัวเองอันนี้ก็อิจฉานะคะใช่นะเหมือนครูุก
อิจฉาครูบีใช่มั้ยสมมุตินะว่าครูบุ๊ก
อิจฉาครูบีเพราะว่าครูบีสวยกว่าครูบุ๊กก็
อยากให้เพื่อนนะไม่ชอบครููบีครูบุ๊กก็เลย
แบบอ่ะไปบอกเพื่อนคนนี้โอยครูบีพูดถึงเธอ
เนี่ยนะว่าเธอเนี่ยโหยขี้เหร่หน้าตาไม่ดี
นะพอเพื่อนได้ยินเพื่อนก็อาจจะรู้สึกแบบ
ไม่ชอบครูบีละโกรธไงใช่แล้วก็บอกเพื่อน
ทุกคนในกลุ่มใช่มั้ยพอเพื่อนเริ่มห่างครู
บีก็จะแบบไม่มีเพื่อนไงอืูก็จะแบบสบายใจ
ละอุ้ย
เหมือนมีความสุขแต่จริงๆไม่ได้มีความสุข
นะคะเพราะว่าอิจฉาใชอืใช่เพราะว่าความคิด
เนี่ยมันไม่ดีไงนะสุขภาพจิตก็จะไม่ดีเนาะ
เหมือนกากาเเนี่ยก็ไม่มีความสุขในการใช้
ชีวิตเพราะว่าอิจฉาหงส์นะวันนี้เราก็เลย
มาพูดถึงเรื่องกากับหงส์นะคะก็เหมือน
ชีวิตคนเราเหมือนกันนะคะก็วันนี้หมดเวลา
แล้วเนาะเราก็มาพบกันใหม่ในครั้งต่อไปนะ
ก็นักเรียนรอฟังแล้วกันนะคะว่าเราจะมี
ท็อปปิกอะไรมาสอนนักเรียนอีกอ่าวันนี้ก็
ขอบคุณค่ะเราลาทุกคนไปก่อนดีมั้ยคะดีค่ะ
พบกันใหม่ค่ะสวัสดี
ค่ะ